so I'm 27 single I live in Austin Texas
the home prices out here are
astronomical I'm in baby step 3B I saved
up about 50,000 for that down payment
and I have about 10,000 in an emergency
fund and my good buddy Roy has been
saying for a long time Kevin ain't no
one is going to want to date you when
you driving that old Honda Accord you
need to get you a sports car what good
buddy Roy is an
idiot oh man I love Roy I really do I do
too but Roy don't know how to pick a
woman if a woman is going to come to you
because of the car you drive you're not
get much of a
woman oh man I pretty much agree with
you wisdom in a multitude of counselors
I'm I'm going around um dude I was on my
third date with my wife in a 1974 Monte
Carlo and we went AC I was telling her
that some I had $2 to my name and I was
telling her someday I'm going to be a
millionaire and we went across the
railroad tracks and the muffler fell off
my car